right so this part here I've just
covered this bit and then I do need to
include this bit off the end because
it's it's not okay right so I'm gonna
say yeah I'm gonna put a word in here
are my choices are and or right I'm
gonna write them down and or okay
who wants to um let's do it this way
it's time I've been I've been putting it
off I'm gonna ask you to put up one
finger for and and two fingers for all
and everyone has to vote okay so and or
I'm looking for one finger or two one
finger or two I figured - okay I'm
waiting for everyone come on commit to
something put that hand up man come on
that's not people can't see all right oh
yeah okay look around okay what is that
is that one or two fingers crossed
that's the count okay all right okay um
let's see here where we gonna begin how
many people have one finger up cut a few
okay over on this table somebody got one
finger or do you all have two fingers
does anyone here on this table have one
for you you go ahead what are you
thinking what makes you think and
mm-hmm so you said actually we might as
well write it I guess before we sort out
this word that goes in between what is
the thing that comes after
well you've change your mind you've just
been so good you're very convincing
obviously okay this last bit here is
gonna be X is greater than 5 so you're
saying and belongs in here because I
really do want both of them yeah you
said this also this okay
someone else who someone said to someone
who said to Sachi what are you thinking
why or that's interested so you use the
word there that we didn't say before you
use the word did anyone catch your joke
you said you said either right and
either doesn't really go with and does
it you can't say either this and this
you go either or this right so that's in
the or camp now before I settle this
right Zacky has said something really
helpful which is it's about values that
X can take so we can actually use this
to settle our argument right well let's
think of a number that we reckon
satisfies this what's a nice easy value
for x that I could put in that would
work too I hear a lot of zeros okay we
like 0 don't we why do we like 0 so much
because it's easy to work with isn't it
it's like I hardly even think right so
let's put this in let's see what happens
I'm going to evaluate the left-hand side
I get when I put 0 take away 2 gives me
negative 2 0 plus 1 gives me 1 0 minus 5
it's negative 5 okay so this of course
is equal to what happens to the double
negative cancels so I just get 10 now is
that greater than 0 it is greater than 0
so in other words what you've told me is
x equals 0 where is that x equals 0
that's here isn't it x equals 0 gives me
10 now by this is a good enough segue as
any to ask bless you
you've just found the y-intercept for me
but I didn't bother finding it before
just does anyone see why I didn't bother
finding it y was not a useful piece of
information for me harassing were you
thinking
right right yeah so long as you're above
the axis I think here how much above the
axis I only care that you are above the
axis okay now we've just decided
together that that zero when you put it
in thumbs up it works okay
is zero between negative one and two it
is there it is
is 0 greater than 5 it is not now the
word and does as we've been say it means
both of them together so zero is this
but it's not that but it satisfies the
original question right so what that
means is if you do one of them but not
the other that's okay right it's either
this or it's that does that make sense
no skin in the game okay do you have a
question resident yeah okay so I'm
deliberately avoiding that symbol for
now just because I mean we did show it
to you as far as I can tell it's not in
the syllabus so where I can use a word
that's clear and it means exactly what I
want to say and also you're gonna have
to read this in questions and you can
have to interpret it I'm gonna try and
prefer that but if you're absolutely in
love with it I'm not gonna stop you at
least at this point okay all right how
are you feeling so far I've got the
answer in equality that was all the
heavy lifting now it should be easier to
do the rest of this okay let's think
back to interval notation okay
the very first thing in interval
notation is you have to say what your
variable is what's your variable its X
good then I use a funky Greek letter
which one the epsilon very good epsilon
like so okay now in interval notation I
have square brackets and then I have
parenthesis which one am I going to use
in this case parentheses why yeah very
good my boundaries are not included okay
so I'm gonna go open one okay said again
yeah sorry we just left out we know we
don't like that negative one in there
okay so I'm gonna go from negative one
to two like so
okay now this point interesting because
rest I mentioned before right when we
showed you this notation earlier because
everything
here is also in symbols we did tend to
see this I was saying this in textbooks
and that kind of thing you could have
said or it would mean the same thing
okay
what will I put afterwards I start at 5
and then I go to where and just like
before right I'm not including any of
these values I'm certainly not including
infinity because you can never get there
can you so I should close with a
parenthesis done okay now last part here
see right on a number line this is the
flat thing now I'm gonna be super cheap
and maybe you would like to be as well
you've actually almost completed this
right you've already drawn your number
line it's right there right watch this
the number line is just the horizontal
part right that's how we've been drawing
number lines since you seven right so in
other words I don't want this stuff and
I don't want this stuff BAM there's my
number line right what I need to do
though now is include the parts like
I've got to color in some stuff that is
the same as this right so which parts
are wearing color in in here this parts
good and then five going that way right
so to the right and I'm done skis Thank
You buzz light you okay